the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
our topic today is the influential
movement called Italian Neorealism
a a movement of filmmakers that arose in
Italy at the end of the Second World War
and had although it was a very
short-lived
movement lasted only six or seven years
before it kind of dissolved of its own
of its own way in part incidentally
because although the films were very
successful with critics and several of
the neo-realist films won Academy Awards
as the best foreign film of the year in
1946 and then again in 1948 when when
the film you're going to see tonight
Bicycle Thieves won the award despite
that acclaim and even global success the
movement sort of petered out although
its influence as I've suggested was very
great one reason the movement petered
out was that forces in Italian society
chambers of commerce types people who
were interested in encouraging the
rebuilding of a devastate of the
devastated cities of Italy a function of
consequence of the of the Second World
War
those folks began to feel that the
messages coming from the Oh realist
films were too negative and we're
discouraging foreign investors so
although it was a very remarkable
movement it lasted only as I say a short
time but its influence ramified very
very very broadly we can trace its
influence to virtually every national
cinema that came after it and there are
there are certain very particular
influences that one can trace from the
neo-realist movement to certain American
directors of film noir in the 40s and
early 50s to certain very interesting
and historically curious forms of
television that emerged in the early
years of American television that were
deeply imitative of and influenced by
Italian neo-realist movies there was
the man that many would identify as the
greatest of all Indian directors sake
Andre was directly inspired to make
movies by the Bicycle Thief and he made
a series of three films that are
essentially a form of Italian Neorealism
moved to India a wonderful trilogy of
films some of them actually about the
untouchable classes in in India called
the Appel trilogy and they are they
remain among the most treasured forms of
Indian of Indian film the Italian
neo-realist had a profound influence on
other European cinemas as well and most
particularly can be said to be the
originating movement behind the french
nouvelle nouvelle vogue the new wave
movement that in France that emerges at
the end of the 50s and the early 60s and
in it involved such now recognized such
directors who now recognized as major
figures in the history of film as
jean-luc Godard and Francois Truffaut so
it was although a short live movement a
profoundly influential one and it
produced some enduring and beautiful and
I guess I would say immortal films the
most famous and perhaps in some ways the
most perfect of those films is the one
you're going to see tonight Bicycle
Thieves and I'll talk a bit about that
film in my introduction to the lecture
this evening I want to begin though by
giving you a sense of how neo realism
feels a kind of a kind of a kind of
distilled version of distilled
embodiment of many of the deepest
principles of neo realism and in order
to do that I want to show you a clip
from the very beginning of the film
you're going to see tonight so you'll
see this beginning twice hopefully the
second time you see it you'll be alive
two more alive to some of its
implications so here is the very opening
of Bicycle Thieves and one of the things
I want to ask you to watch for is first
how much information
how much visual information dramatic
information becomes available to you
under the titles and then how fluently
and fluidly the film moves out of the
title sequence into a kind of
continuation of the drama that's
articulated in that title sequence on
the surface this little anecdote at the
very beginning of the film seems very
modest and one might even think of it as
simply expository that it's to providing
information to the audience so that they
can get on with the story as I hope
you'll recognize and as I'll try to show
you briefly after I've shown you the
clip much more is going on in that and
it's a particularly wonderful example of
the way in which the best neo-realist
films generate a kind of texture a kind
of density what I've sometimes called a
multiplicity that we have suggested in
this course is one of the fundamental
ways in which you can distinguish
between entertainment and serious
entertainment or between entertainment
and art when items and objects begin to
have this multiplicity when they begin
to serve multiple functions not just a
single function you're in the presence
of something not only complex but
something that acknowledges the
complexity of the world in some in some
respects and this opening sequence of
Bicycle Thieves
does this with remarkable economy now
here's the beginning of the film
great can you freeze it for a second
well one thing I should mention while
you're watching this to interrupt the
sequence for a moment the activity that
you see taking place under the titles is
supposed to be confusing at first
although after a while it begins to
clarify perhaps you're not fully clear
what is going on until the titles
disappear and you see these men
assembling around that staircase there
where a man with a list is speaking to
them what is going on here is what in in
in in the United States in the in the
40s and 50s on the law on the docks in
New York they called the shape up and a
shape up is a place where men who are
eager for work sort of come and hang
around and wait for the boss the the
foreman or the or the hiring boss to
pick them out of the crowd shape ups are
always unpleasant experiences because
there are many people who are excluded
and the people who are chosen are often
this was especially true on the New York
waterfront in the days when which I know
about because my father was a
longshoreman for a while it was a
particularly bad thing in the New York
waterfront because you had to know
somebody to get work I don't know if
that's an implication here or not
although you'll see as the men
complained that some of them have that
suspicion in any case what's going on
here is what is called a shape-up men
are gathered around men who are
unemployed looking for work
my mother she's democracy one quick quiz
they're more popular worship of fun I
mean after keep the never sent our
children assuming is the character
except our daily bread China entered a
no one man shall be JD from diesel you
know Janice tell me I did he go there is
about a vision later
hor visually just escrito por el dedo
Lolita cello in cello so because of the
truth I know chose to be does it on
interview in other word visually that
should say this again vamos a gallery
chair I wrote shall I stop wishing it to
challenge over the rock
Oh
right
I wish I could let the scene run on but
I hope you I hope you I can tell some of
you are responding to what you saw there
make some observations about what you
saw there what that in that introduction
what do we learn as an audience you have
to be fast I only have a few minutes
here yes
alright one thing we know is that
there's a lot of unemployment in this
guy right and there's a lot of
discontent and then the minute he says I
don't have a bicycle virtually everyone
else in the crowd says I am a bias
everyone is desperate for a job not just
reaching that's right so there and he he
we learned how grateful he is but also
how how troubled he is what is what's
the evidence in the film that he is
really very unhappy very very troubled
by the fact that he doesn't have a
bicycle to get this job after so long
what's the most dramatic piece of
evidence we see that he's distracted by
his anxiety he doesn't help his wife
with the water yes it's a very dramatic
scene isn't it
she she's walking behind him carrying
these too heavy but and he doesn't
ignore her because he's a nasty
patriarch who thinks that women should
carry water he he's so distracted he
doesn't notice it and in fact what he
walks down that that little incline and
looks back and sees her struggling and
goes back and as soon as he recognized
that he takes one from her and it's
significant isn't it that he takes only
one from her is if they're really
partners I mean it and it's also what
else is significant she doesn't yell at
him she doesn't say my god Ricci what
kind of a pig are you making me carry
all this stuff by myself right because
she shares his his anxiety and his
concern doesn't she so on the surface
what the the the seat the scene
certainly dramatizes reaches desperate
need for for it for a job and the fact
that he's one of many people in a
similar situation but what does it tell
us about his marriage on the basis of
these details what you just saw in this
beginning do you think he has a good
marriage that he has a good relationship
with his wife that it's a mutually
trusting relationship that they of
course of course right and how would we
know that we know that from that detail
now the detail does not advance the plot
in the sense of telling us anything
further about his need for the bicycle
or its unemployment but it does reveal
to us something about their marriage
about the kind of man he is
about the kind of woman she is right so
that it's a moment in which his anxiety
about his job is
maybe the primary thing we see but what
is also dramatized for us is the nature
of their relationship and it's
dramatized for us without anyone coming
out and saying let me show you a
mutually engaged couple who depend on
each other and who survive in part
because they share each other's troubles
people whose respect for each other is
so total that even when one of them
commits a really mean or at least or or
or at least unpleasant act by ignoring
his wife struggles she doesn't even
think to complain to him about it
because she shares his anxiety so that's
it's an example of what I mean by a
moment of multiplicity in which
something about their relationship
something about their marriage emerges
even as we are also learning something
about the economic circumstances in
which these characters live say a little
bit more about the scene that you saw
how about the place where she's drawing
water what about that wide wood there in
a city there they're walking in fact to
a high-rise apartment house in which
they live what does it mean that she's
carrying two buckets of water to an
apartment and then she's going to climb
up four flights or three flights to get
to their apartment what does that tell
us about Mussolini's Italy there's no
running water in the building in the in
the high-rise apartments right and not
just that is the water precious how do
you know it is say but yes but what else
where do they get the water is the water
did they go to a pump in the open square
no it's in a barbed wire compound right
again
these details may not register instantly
as deeply significant but think what
they tell us about the conditions of
urban life in Rome in 1947 or 1948 when
the film is when the film is said you
have and and and you could even go
further look more closely at the setting
did anything grow there it looked like
they were walking across a wasteland of
mud except for these high-rise tenement
buildings so we have tie rise tenement
buildings set down in a kind of desert
right placing buildings that don't even
have running water in which in which the
main water pump has to be protected by
barbed wire right so that it's almost as
if in this brief introduction to the
film
the whole socio-economic environment of
the story has been established for us
without anyone giving us lectures about
it or calling our attention to it that's
what I mean by multiplicity when the
details of the film served character and
served plot and serve our sense of the
environment right so it's a it's a rich
moment it's a moment it's a moment of
art it's a moment of complexity it's a
moment of human truthfulness then that
resonates for us as the as the film as
the film goes on well there are many
many moments like this virtually every
moment in Bicycle Thieves
has this kind of density or texture has
this kind of implication built into the
particular details I want to very
quickly set the kind of the context for
I've already implied the context for the
neo-realist movement the basic context
is the end of World War two most
historians trace the beginnings of the
neo-realist movement to two films that
were made under Mussolini while while
while the war was still going on and
some people actually date the very
beginning of of the movement - a film
made in 1942 by Luchino Visconti called
obsession it's actually a an adaptation
of a very popular American pulp novel
called The Postman Always Rings Twice
it's been made twice into an English
language American movie but most
recently starring Jack Nicholson the but
but but they attend the Italian version
maybe the most the most important and
interesting of the films made from the
book the the the book itself is a rather
tawdry Moorish story about about a the
owner of a diner who's who an ugly
middle-aged pug who's married to a
beautiful and somewhat younger woman who
very unhappy with her husband begins an
affair with a drifter who comes by and
ultimately encourages the drifter to
kill her husband
and it's a it's actually a rather a
rather heavy-handed male chauvinist
fantasy about about the report Li about
about how cunning and dangerous women
are the Italian version is much more
interesting in part because the
working-class dimensions of the story
are given much greater emphasis in
Luchino Visconti's version and the film
partly becomes a kind of meditation on
the fate of undocumented workers and
non-union workers in in metallian
society in any case the emphasis on
ordinary people and the emphasis on
socio-economic circumstances in that
film by Visconti came to be defining
features among the defining features of
Italian neo-realist filmmaking but the
movement really doesn't get going until
after the war and the context of the war
is very important we need to recognize
that the film is really set in a
devastated society a society in which
I'm talking now about all of Europe
after the Second World War
unemployment reached at 25 or 30 percent
higher in some societies there was
economic turmoil in virtually every
European society profound terrible
pressures from black market activities
of all kinds the Devon the war was so
devastating that something on the order
of 35 percent of all the permanent
dwellings in Western Europe were
destroyed during the war the 25 percent
of the Polish population was killed a
tremendous proportion virtually every
well a very large number of Italian
cities were damaged very badly including
of course Rome itself and there's a and
these these abject and terrifying
economic conditions were were of course
in Italy doubled by the problem that
Italy was on the losing side in the war
and had and and therefore faced even
more difficulties in a rack are in their
recovery then then a culture like the
French culture or the or-or-or Engel
Society so so the devastation of World
War two in the turmoil and and
dislocation caused by World War two is
the fundamental fact in words what what
it's still operative in Italian society
what institutions still work is one of
the implicit questions that the film
explores and the film suggests that a
lot of the official institutions like
the police and the and their and and
especially the religious institutions
have broken down and are not really
helping people very much as you'll see
when you when you watch tonight's film
but that there are there are other forms
of help and aid that people get mostly
in some sense from their the film
suggests from their local communities
and from there and from and from their
immediate families well to this basic
sort of setting of devastation and
turmoil and economic uncertainty we need
we need to add two other contextual
factors both of them having to do with
the film traditions against which
neo-realism
said itself against which it understood
itself to be are to be in in in in a
kind of profound argument the first
tradition was the tradition of fascist
film under Mussolini these World very
almost all studio films they were shot
inside studios neo-realist films are
shot outdoors and they all and they were
largely escapist they were largely
escapist fare focusing more often than
not on the upper social orders in fact
there was a genre of film so devoted to
the romantic entanglements of
aristocrats that they came to be known
as white telephone films the reason for
this is that in the old days before
cellphones and before multi-coloured
phones all telephones were black and it
was a mark of astonishing aristocratic
privilege that the people in some of
these films had white telephones they
were such unusual objects for the time
that the films came to be labeled as
white telephone films and they were
largely as I said escapist movies of
with with beautifully made-up actors and
actresses in artificial light performing
what worse
actually artificial stories the second
tradition against which the neorealists
are responding against which they are
reacting is the tradition of Hollywood
glamour there's a wonderful moment in
the Bicycle Thief and eul's as you'll
see tonight when Ricci finally goes off
to get his job he recovers his bicycle
from hock it's he's pawned it and that's
why he's so nervous he knows where the
bicycle is but he doesn't know how
they're gonna get it out of porn and
you'll see how his wife solves that
problem
in the very next sequences being beyond
the one I've just shown to you when
Ricci finally goes to work for the first
time he has someone with him giving him
instructions and what he is is a bill
sticker he puts up posters grapeo in
fact the poster that he's putting up as
opposed to for an American movie and it
has a great amount of a masseuse or of
the 40s and 50s Rita Hayworth on the on
it and as he's putting the picture up
you put pasted on the board then he's
giving him these stupid instructions
because anyone could do this job but the
man giving him instructions acts as if
he's explaining something really
difficult like like rocket science
when Wally's doing is telling him how to
paste a poster up on a board but his but
his instructions include a systematic
remarks about being sure not to leave
any wrinkles in it and I've taken that
myself to be a kind of implicit
complaint against Hollywood okay let's
say the Hollywood the Hollywood female
has no wrinkles the Hollywood female the
Hollywood star the Hollywood movie is so
glamorized that you never see wrinkles
or defects and this couldn't contrast
more sharply with the ordinary faces of
the actors that we see in neo-realist
films so two traditions of glamour and
of and of escapism are essentially the
antagonists that that that that that
that helped to explain how neo-realism
defines itself and under and understands
itself it's worth briefly mentioning
that neo realism has distinguished
origins in at least three different
national cinemas the first is in Italian
cinema itself
there was a movement in during the
silent era a kind of documentary
movement that wanted to talk as quasi
documentary movement with it they were
still fiction films but they wanted to
talk more openly and honestly about
contemporary events in contemporary
society and the movement was called the
verismo movement the truth movement
right and occurred between 1914 and 1916
in Italy and this and when the Neel when
when the neorealists began to articulate
their own manifestos and to explain
theoretically what they were up to
they sometimes reached back to the
verismo movement as a way of saying
we're actually traditional as well as
new a second fundamental influence on
neo realism a kind of earlier version of
neo realism occurred in the German
tradition at the end of the silent era
in a series of films made in the 1920s
by the director GW papst
PA BST his most famous of these films as
a film produced in 1925 called the
joyless Street and partly deals with
prostitutes and it and it and it talks
in it tries to dramatize in realistic
ways the conditions of the lower social
orders and of course the final
originating source this also explains
the richness of neo realism that there
are these other film traditions that are
feeding into it and enriching it is
French and it's the it's the kind of
French film that we associate with Jean
Renoir and with the traditions of poetic
realism some of the neo-realist one of
the at least one of the neo-realist
directors Visconti had worked as an
assistant director for jean renoir
at one point in his career and i I
believe I'm not sure this is accurate so
don't take this as absolute fact but I
believe that it was Renoir himself who
gave a copy of The Postman Always Rings
Twice to this Conte - which led to the
creation of what many people would
identify as the very first neo-realist
green neo-realist film the basic
practices and traditions of poetic
realism are carried over in neo realism
and in one sense one can see neo realism
as an extension of poetic realism the
difference is that neo realism
more political and social orientation
it's more conscious of having a
political and social ambition they wants
to it where and and and sometimes
neo-realist films can seem a bit preachy
because of that I mean there's a there's
clearly a kind of a sentiment the deeply
sympathetic to the lower social order is
deeply suspicious of the hierarchies of
capitalism some some of the neorealists
were Marxists or Marxist sympathizers
and that helps to explain the political
orientation of neo-realist films but the
basic features of poetic realism the use
of an outdoor camera the interest in
Amazon Sen style and in a film made by
which I mentioned I think last time made
by Renoir in 1935 a film called tony teo
and i we have a french version of neo
realism because that film as i mentioned
last time is about italian quarry
workers in the south of france and it
has a lot of non-professional actors in
it something that became a key feature
of neo-realism
so the neo-realist movement then has
this powerful context which creates a
kind of moral and and and aesthetic
energy that helps to explain the power
and the excitement of these films it has
two very clear antagonists the glamour
of Hollywood and the the false and
aristocratic glamour of the film under
Mussolini and it also draws as well on
older traditions of film in Italian in
German and in French that set earlier
examples for the kind of thing that the
neo-realist want to do I've already
talked about the key features of
neo-realism when I just a second to go
when I spoke about poetic realism but
let me mention some of those key
features in a little bit more detail one
way to think about neo-realist films us
to recognize that their emphasis on
reality is one which insists on trying
to create an illusion of plaus of a
plausible actuality and what this meant
to them was listen people have warts on
their noses
people are not beautiful the way they
are in Hollywood let's so one thing we
need to do is we need to roughen up the
look of our performers and in fact
professional actors it was felt often
bring a kind of smoothness or a fluidity
to their performance that is inherently
artificial so many neo-realist films
have no or virtually no professional
actors in them or sometimes only
professional actors in the major roles
in the film you're going to see tonight
the star was a non-professional actor he
actually ended up having a tragic life
even the film won the Academy Award is
the best foreign film of the year in
America in 1948 and the man who played
Ricci beat was an instant became an
international star but he he fell into
hard times and and ended up not not
really making much making much money off
his off from his from his very brief
stardom and then and and my
understanding is that that he that he
never again made a film as remarkable as
the Bicycle Thief but one of the things
that is absolutely astonishing about the
performance is that this man is not an
actor you would never guess it I mean
it's an absolute or maybe it would but
you would guess it only after having
been told that because if he performs
with such naturalness in such grace so
the use of non-professional actors is it
was one of the key features of
neo-realism
a second key feature is a rejection of
studio filming all neo-realist films
like almost all poetic realism films
realist films were shot outdoors in
natural light partly because they wanted
natural light and partly because studios
lie about the texture of the world we
want the texture of the world in our
films the nearer our films are really
about reality so we can't shoot in we
can't shoot indoors a third
non-professional actors outdoor camera a
third feature would be what we might
call a fundamental meson sense style
taken directly from the the stylistic
habits established by Jean Renoir and
other French directors who worked in the
same style relatively modest forms of
editing the forms of montage that you
see are are not disruptive you won't get
jump cuts or or disorienting moments the
camera
the camera is as with Renoir constantly
Restless and in motion but often in very
gentle ways there's a wonderful motion
moment in the scene I mentioned a moment
to go where we see Ricci putting up his
first poster when the camera is watching
them and and and he's getting these
instructions from his comrade about how
to put the thing up and it's really
boring
well the weed one reason that you know
it's boring it would obviously you as a
viewer you begin to probably feel it
without registering that it's boring but
the wait reason that you know it is is
that the camera suddenly looks away what
happens is the camera discovers
something interesting happening on the
street and while the conversation
continues on the soundtrack the camera
shifts away from Ricci and his
instructor and follows a wealthy man and
two children who are walking behind him
and they're really beggars trying to get
money from him and the camera just just
it found it interesting so it looked at
it a very John Renoir --is-- move there
are other moves like this so in the in
the film as if the camera like Jean
Renoir's camera is so interested in the
world that it's capable of being
distracted there's a sense that the
world's complexity is always threatening
the the coherences and meanings that the
film is releasing for us so
non-professional actors outdoor filming
Amazon said a profound serious meson
sense style influenced by deeply by Jean
Renoir and finally we might maybe
another not finally one more a fourth
feature we might say is what what I what
I was trying to indicate when I talked
about the social or political bias of
these films one might say that these
films have a more profoundly documentary
flavor I don't mean that we feel we're
watching documentaries but we watch we
do feel we're watching a slice of life
that the economic and moral and social
and personal circumstances of the
characters we see in neo-realist films
are a version of what we would find if
we walked into Rome not in a movie and
just look for people of this class right
a documentary flavor so that's four
features and a final feature that I
suppose I would want to add has to do
with the relation between plot and
character it's not quite true to say
that these films are plotless they're
not and one of the most magnificent
things about the Bicycle Thief is the
economy of its plot and I'll talk a bit
about that tonight but it's nonetheless
true that in neo-realist films you do
not feel that action drives events what
you feel is that character drives events
in some sense that the that the plot is
an what the plot aims for is a natural
unfolding you're never supposed to feel
in a neo realist film that that some
event in the plot has been introduced
arbitrarily you're never supposed to
step back and say oh that could never
happen no that's how implausible is that
or I guess they did that because they
wanted to show X right the kind of
response you often have watching certain
forms of Hollywood entertainment and and
other other forms of merely escapist
entertainment fair but you don't ever
have that feeling in a good real
neo-realist film what you feel is that
the events of the plot unfold naturally
out of the economic and social realities
the characters live in and out of their
characters you can test this
generalization against tonight's film
and I'm sure that you'll find that it's
a compelling one that it really
describes this movements respect for the
complexity of character over plot for
the complexity of character and
therefore for its commitment to a kind
of movie that is a more interested in
character than it is in in story or
event in a narrow sense the central
figures of neo realism are important to
mention and maybe especially the fellow
that I have first on my list here cesare
zavattini because he's the least
well-known of the names I've listed
there the other three names are all
famous directors and of course to see
cuz the director of Bicycle Thieves and
I'll talk about his career this evening
but Sabatini was the theoretical genius
behind neo realism and a figure for whom
I still retain a tremendous sympathy and
affection he he was a novelist and a an
essay writer as well as a screen
screenwriter he collaborated with with
Vittorio De Sica on
most every one of the seekers in
significant films not on everyone but on
all of them
virtually everyone that is truly
outstanding and there are a number of
them he's he's the the scriptwriter on
and he had a particularly symbiotic
relation to De Sica Sabatini also
articulated what came to be understood
as the manifesto of neo-realism and in
one such essay I don't know it was
titled manifesto of neo-realism but that
was its effect he said this to try to
summarize what he thought the ambitions
of neo-realism were he said a good film
ought to be focused on on the life of an
ordinary man to whom nothing happens now
he didn't really mean that nothing would
happen right it's not it's not an early
version of the Seinfeld program what
what what what what he's trying to get
at is this idea that plot does not
dominate that character dominates that
the events of the story grow organically
out of the materials of the of the text
both out of character and out of out of
social and out of social realities so
the Sabbatini was in many ways a
visionary figure an overt Marxist for a
good part for a good part of his life
and probably the central intellectual
influence on the neo-realist movement
this Conte the great the director whose
dates I put there but is sometimes
suggested it is often said that not all
of this country's work fits neatly maybe
none of it fits neatly into the category
of neo-realism and this partly has to do
with it with a kind of flamboyance in in
in in Visconti's visual style and maybe
also a fondness for decadence and for
and for elaboration that does not
comport with the social meanings that
are implicit in neo realism so he's the
of the main neo-realist he's he's the
one who fits least well but he's often
said to be the best of them and there
are many historians of film and scholars
of film in
shooting David Cook who believed that
the earth trembles the film that he made
in 1948 la terre prima the earth
trembles is the greatest of all
neo-realist movies I have sometimes been
tempted to show it but it's less
characteristic of neo-realism
so I don't show it but it is a very
remarkable film and this country is a
very important figure in this in this
movement even though he probably can be
said in his later films too to move
beyond neo-realist concerns roberto
rossellini who also had a very rich long
career as a filmmaker and I've only
listed his one film there because I want
to show you a clip from it it's part of
a trilogy of films he made at the very
end of the war called it was called his
Roman trilogy or his Rome trilogy and
the first one was world war ii trilogy
the first one was called Rome open City
and then there were two other the third
one was called Germany Year Zero and
they all had sort of political and
social ambitions they wanted to
dramatize the post-war conditions and
show the devastation that followed the
the aftermath that that was the
aftermath of the Second World War
open city had a tremendous impact when
it was first released especially in
Italy because it told an anti-fascist
story it's a somewhat melodramatic film
that that ends in a very in a very
melodramatic death in a very
melodramatic murder
acts or an accidental murder and and and
and partly for that reason it's it's
unless it's a less powerful and less
compelling film totally than something
like Bicycle Thieves but it but but it's
importances can't be overestimated it
established the basic principles that
I've been talking about it was actually
begun before the war was over when it
was illegal to when the when the German
authorities were status authorities were
still controlling Rome and Italian
society and you weren't supposed to you
couldn't film without a license and ro
some of the early scenes from Rome
open city were actually shot illicitly
on very bad film stock from behind
doorways and around corners so the
people the people behind the camera
wouldn't be caught by the authorities
and then the film was completed after
peace came and after after the after the
defeat of the Axis forces I'm going to
show you a clip from that sequence from
that film from the very beginning of
that film to give you a feel for what
that film is like as well and I think
that that clip will also show you why
the film was so successful but I'll
partly explain it now I think the
Italians love this movie because it told
a useful myth it made it made it appear
that very few Italians collaborated with
the Nazis and that most Italians were
really on the side of the saboteurs who
were trying to blow up fascist
waterworks and but this is probably not
entirely historically accurate since
Mussolini was during much of his career
a very popular figure in Italy but you
can certainly understand why it would
have hit a sympathetic court among
Italians many of whom I'm sure felt
terrible ambivalence and shame over the
over the events of the of the Second
World War the Italians were always much
more reluctant anti-semites than the
Hitler fascists were and the story of
Italian anti-fan tie semitism is much
more complicated than the story of
German anti-semitism in this in this
period especially so I think that one
reason for the success of the film had
to do with the way it told a kind of
anti-fascist fable that worked
particularly well for this post-war
society that wanted to put fascism
behind it that wanted to repudiate that
past that felt there were certainly
segments of the population that had
never gone along with that past anyway
so the film sort of mobilized feel a new
kind of feeling of Italian patriotism
and maybe even some in some sense a kind
of despite the catastrophe in which it
ends a kind of hope for the future
because the film takes place entirely
within the period when the when the
fascists were still in control of Italy
and the catastrophe that occurs at the
end isn't isn't is
is an act of fascist murder and
assassinate open and indifference to
humanity the so so um mostly Rossellini
went on to make many many films and I
feel a little guilty only mentioning
this one not totally characteristic film
of his but it's important in the history
of neo-realism Rosellini is a director I
much admire partly because he moved away
from fiction and at the end of his
career he was he was making what he
thought of as educational or
instructional films oh but but but with
the dazzling technique of a great
fiction filmmaker so he's a very
interesting figure to to study and to
and I hope some of you will will look at
more neo-realist films and consider
looking at Rossellini De Sica is the
final figure that I want to mention as a
fundamental energy in neo realism and
I'll only say about him that he's
probably the most various and gifted of
all the of all the neo-realist figures
partly because he had been a very
successful actor on before he became a
director and I'll talk a bit more about
to seek of this evening what I want to
illustrate now in the in the time we
have left is an aspect of the
neo-realist aesthetic if we could use
that term that I've talked about before
when we discussed Renoir and that I
implied in earlier comments that I made
this afternoon it's what I call the
neo-realist counter plot and what by
counter plot what I really want to call
attention to are all those elements in
the film that seem not to take part in
the forward momentum of the story what
we might even think of them as retarding
elements in which the in which these
films will sort of pause to smell the
roses it's all a version of what I mean
of what I mean by this we're neo-realist
counterplot might be said to be embodied
in that in that astonishing camera move
we studied at the end of Buddha say from
browning last week where the camera
makes a 180 degree
swerve becomes interested in the beauty
of the of the river becomes interested
in the scenery almost as if it's
forgotten its character right now what I
mean by the counterplot is this impulse
in these films and especially in these
Italian films to to to complicate the
social and political and even the
psychological processes of the story
simply in order to give us a sense of
what the experience it's describing is
like as if it's a version of what I of
what I'm interested in what I talked
about how the camera can distract itself
and one way I can illustrate what is so
what I mean by counter plot then are
energies that [ __ ] or slow down the
basic the basic story or that seem not
to directly contribute to the basic
story but are but but but remain part of
the film's desire to represent the world
to represent reality in something of its
complexity in something of its nuance
even in something of its contradictory
incoherence right goods I don't really
want to call these moments in coherent
moments they're not because they build a
much larger and more complete picture of
the whole world you're looking at in
that sense they're not incoherent but
but but they are a kind of counter to
the ongoing pressure to find out what
happens next what happens next what
happens next well there are many many
examples of this principle in the
Bicycle Thief and in other neo-realist
films but I want to show you one very
dramatic one also to give you a set of
flavor for an earlier neo-realist film
other than the one you're going to see
tonight this is from the very beginning
of Open City
let me associate
these are residents of Rome they heard
an explosion there sabotage going on in
Rome doubts near the end of the war the
war is not over
and now the saboteurs return home and
look who they turn out to be
and of course that's why and the
bhagnani was the actress was worried
about where the children were because
they suspected
there's already a counterplot operator
new I hope you see what look at these
are the innocent faces
so these saboteurs have now come home
I'm stopping it a little early the scene
continues you actually go into another
room in a moment and you see children in
a kind of dormitory like room in which
there's one little child sitting on a
potty and I think it's the first potty
scene in western film then they do
something very disturbing too they pick
him off the potty and put him back in
bed without wiping him but leave it
maybe there was no toilet paper in
post-war Italy but I your laughter
indicated to me that you sort of got the
point but talk to me a little bit about
what you see there mean what it's a
wonderful example of what I was trying
to illustrate at the beginning as well
this principle of multiplicity what's
happening in this sequence what what do
we learn what about living conditions in
Rome what do we learn nobody gives a
lecture about it what what you think
there are as a housing crisis in Rome
seven families living together in the
same room
an old man in bed lying in a bed in the
parlor right in the middle in the space
whether in the living space of the place
right he so that that's clearly where he
stays he's very ill right what else the
deviation into comedy the extent right
the mean the extent to which a kind of a
kind of series of comic encounters occur
after what after a moment of political
sabotage right and the incongruity of
these little children who are the ones
who are the saboteurs is also part of
the comedy even before we see them fully
return to the condition of children when
their parents start slapping him in
there in the faces and saying how dare
you stay out so late I didn't mean to
suggest that the parents actually know
that the children are saboteurs although
although some may but I think the point
is that being outside at night in is
very dangerous for little children in
this environment and that's why they're
so concerned but they but but the fact
that even the children are partisan
anti-fascist fighters becomes a part of
what the film is about so the now you
can't tell from the very beginning from
this beginning what the real sort of
plot energy of the film is yet can you
and it will take a bit longer before it
finally turns out the man that she's
about to marry is a is a is a secret
agent and he's been he's under he's a he
he's being he's being hunted by the
fascist authorities and the film is
about how he's how how the good Italians
try to hide him what but we don't learn
that yet
and I want to suggest you is something
of life's variety something of life's
comedy something of life's incongruity
emerges for us in those moments and it's
what I want to call a counterplot
because we take delight in those moments
we don't be get impatient and say come
on film tell me where you're going
because what the film teaches us is that
it's not in that narrow sense of our
plot at all but it's about life in its
infinite complexity the greatest
neo-realist films embrace this principle
as well as any films I've ever known and
in addition they have a kind of moral
authority that's very rare
I'm very jealous of those of you in this
course who have never seen the Bicycle
Thief because it is a remarkable film
that I'm sure you'll remember for the
rest of your
I'll see you tonight
you